[Musique]
eric darques de plus en plus blancs des
de plus en plus ravissants tu dis ça
parce que d'une part c'est vrai et
d'autre part parce qu'autant vous avez
l'air à l'aise quand vous chantez autant
insiste là devant moi vers pas du tout
du tout du tout dans notre assiette
c'est vrai je vais pas paniquer comment
ça je sais pas c'est toujours assez
impressionnant de faire un interview je
pourrais vous et puis de parler de soi
c'est un jeu pensé gênant à croire aussi
en vous regardant le travail ça concerne
je crois vous tournez beaucoup oui un
peuvent pas beaucoup beaucoup map
quand je pense que vous enchaînez film
sur tille un non pas du tout l'habitude
non non je fais deux trois films dans
l'année mais je fais d'autres choses à
côté fhv tête des photos beaucoup et
puis des émissions de variétés pour la
télévision
j'aime beaucoup on est là on entend
souvent parler de vous et si bien que ça
donne l'impression que vous tournez
énormément oui peut-être le moi je ne
veux pas faire beaucoup de films non aux
excuses du coup jean mus les gens je
trouve que vous avez fait beaucoup de
progrès en chantant vous travaillez
beaucoup à pouvoir un peu pas énormément
mais peut-être j'ai peut-être que
peut-être que je sais pas j'écoute fait
plus et autres chanter maintenant qu'à
vous aussi qui aimez vous j'aime
beaucoup de genres
j'aime c'est nina simone nice et par
dessus tout puis en france j'aime bécaud
j'aime j'aime régine j'aime beaucoup par
part a énormément
je crois que j'ai beaucoup de presque
tous les jours par bara je trouve que
vous choisi sa vie je voyais beaucoup de
gens mais ça veut dire comment faites
vous pour le choix des chansons bien en
général ça se passe en famille c'est à
dire que ce sont des gens que j'aime
bien qui m'écrivent des chansons gaz
bourg quelquefois pas souvent parce
qu'il a beaucoup de travail
vidal a-data puis botton maintenant je
crois que vous avez besoin que les
choses se passent en fait ah oui
énormément
j'ai besoin de travailler avec des gens
qui m'aiment on a cette impression
à première vue comme ça de le filtrer
primesautière très très vivante très
très gai en impression vous avez besoin
d'être de temps en temps est chauffée
pas dans l'amitié des zones presque tout
le temps parce que voter oui même au
cinéma enfin j'aime bien travailler avec
l'équipe lautner audiard parce que c'est
ma famille aussi
c'est sur le plan professionnel vous
fait vous êtes parfaitement content de
votre soeur ou est ce que vous voudriez
autre chose non moi je suis très court
par ces très contente parce que
finalement si vous voulez je crois
qu'une carrière c'est on se la fait
soi-même et moi je crois que c'est la
mienne je sais pas tous les jours
satisfaite des films que je fais c'est
pas ça non c'est pas du tout contente
plus mais si vous voulez d'un autre côté
si je fais quelque chose de mauvais mais
là j'en suis responsable entièrement
saharien vient rarement si ça arrive non
mais c'est bon je me suis trompé c'est
tout mais si vous voulez de notre côté
je sais aussi que quand je fais quelque
chose qui nous plaît ou qui plaît c'est
aussi moi qui suis responsable et je si
vous voulez personne n'oblige de choisir
un sujet ou un metteur en scène je n'ai
pas de deux contraintes et les parties
notre crainte que je m'énerve
[Musique]